Hey everyone, welcome back to the
channel. Uh, for those of you who are
OGs around these parts, uh, you can see
we're back in my original childhood
bedroom where I was making uh, the
systems design 1.0 series. So, I'm
getting a little nostalgic about it. Um,
but yeah, it's been a good week. Been
off, uh, not working, which is
fantastic. And, uh, to support all of
this extra time, uh, that I've had on my
hands, we're probably cutting down quite
a few extra trees in the, uh, the Amazon
rainforest to support my paper usage.
But let's go ahead and get into some
videos. Today we're going to be talking
about Robin Hood. Um, I made a
collaboration video on this a while back
on a different channel and uh I was
sufficiently roasted by it uh from a lot
of users in the comments. So, let's see
if uh we can do a little bit better this
time and uh try and keep the focus down.
Are you a Robin Hood user that thinks
you can beat the market? Guess what? You
probably can't. But if you want to give
it a shot, you should probably get your
skills up. That's where Brilliant comes
in. Brilliant is a platform that allows
you to self-study various STEM topics
like math, data science, computer
science, and machine learning. As I age,
I've come to accept that my chances of
becoming an alpha male gym tank are
pretty low since I'm too soft to inject
steroids into my body. Instead, I'm
going to go the alternate route of
attempting to attract my wife with
monetary success and perhaps if I stop
looking at blind, my intelligence, too.
I found that in particular, Brilliant's
new LLM course has been a major enabler
for me to learn about key topics in
modern artificial intelligence. It
allows you to get hands-on experience
with real language models. I can
supplement that with Brilliant's great
courses on statistics and probability to
become a self-taught quant. Now, instead
of trading GameStop options expiring
today, Citadel can get my flow in
commodities and crypto. To try
everything that Brilliant has to offer
for free for 30 days, check out
brilliant.org/jordanhasnolife
org/jordanasnolife
or click the link in the description.
You'll also get 20% off of an annual
subscription to premium. Okay, so as I
mentioned, I've kind of made this video
before uh albeit not on this channel.
So, you know, I wanted to take the
opportunity to go ahead and remake it
using uh my typical format and see if it
could help people out. Uh the gist is I
think that uh one thing people were
particularly hostile towards last time
was I went into probably the the finance
and the like stock specific and option
specific aspects of things a little bit
more than was necessary. And in this
episode I'm still going to touch upon
those because I do think it's essential
to kind of understand some of the
dynamics there to actually build out
Robin Hood and understand the actual
complexity of the problem. But I'm not
going to go as deep into it because to
tell you the truth there are many
different ways of you know calculating
the price of a stock and option. it's
it's not really worth discussing them
for too long. Probably 90% of the time a
tech company is going to give you this
interview and you know they're not
really going to care so long as you kind
of get the essence of the problem. So,
let's go ahead and get into it. As you
can see, we've got Robin Hood over here
on the screen. This would be an example
of my portfolio, which obviously is
quite going to be down uh since I've
been listening to Wall Street Bets a
little bit too much. So, I've got
GameStop, Dogecoin, AMC, some GameStop
call expiring, let's see, in 2 days from
now. And then we've also got Karina
Copcoin. That's a new one. And pretty
much all of those are doing quite
poorly. So you can see I've got my total
portfolio value. We can see, you know,
on the front end at least we've got a
chart of some historical prices as well.
But mainly what I care about uh for this
problem because I think that's going to
be the more interesting component of all
of this is number one that we should be
able to buy and sell financial products.
So Robin Hood is a brokerage, right?
you're not actually buying and selling
things through them or with other Robin
Hood users, but they're basically
routing your orders to a stock exchange
or an option exchange or something along
those lines. So, we're not going to go
too much into actually building the
exchange itself. That's worthy of a
completely entirely separate video,
which we'll do eventually, but uh for
right now, we're just going to focus on
Robin Hood. Um, and then additionally,
we want to be able to see the real-time
value of our assets, and these are
changing constantly. So we're going to
talk about that a little bit more as
well as total portfolio value. So total
portfolio value can be derived really
simply from knowing the value of every
single asset on the front end. You can
just go ahead and you know take every
asset that you have multiply it by the
quantity that you own of it and then
that's your total portfolio value. So
that that part's pretty simple but uh
getting the actual price of every asset
is not so simple. Number three is that
we want to minimize the number of
servers that we have listening to the
exchange. So this is one of those
finance specific pieces, right? Because
you might think, oh well, you know, why
not just have 10,000 servers listening
to the exchange to get information for
every user and then dissipate it to a
particular user. Servers are pretty
inexpensive. We can just have a cheap
EC2 instance. Well, for starters, uh
there's a lot of load on these servers
that have to listen to the exchange
because exchanges publish tons of
information. And number two, it actually
costs money for us to listen to the
exchange. So that's a pretty
fundamentally important part of uh
getting some Exchange data as you don't
want to actually just have tons of
servers that you've registered to listen
to it. Okay. And then three, just for
the for the sake of a brief capacity
estimate, I'm going to estimate around
100 million users, 100 million daily
active users. Someone got mad at me in
the comment section of the last time for
not explicitly saying that. And we'll
estimate that on average each user has
maybe a 100 different instruments in
their portfolio where an instrument
could be, let's say, a stock or an
option.
So the first thing that I want to do is
lay out a couple of initial thoughts for
this problem because I think this
particular framework is going to allow
us to kind of you know start from a
given and then derive the the remainder
of our solution from there. So number
one is that most people who use Robin
Hood are using it from their cell phone.
It's a phone app and so I actually don't
even know if they support a computer
app. I think they do but it's pretty
poor anyway. So because we're connecting
via mobile device the majority of the
time we want to limit the amount of load
that we're actually putting on that
device. And so typically what that means
is we want to limit the number of active
connections. And so if you're thinking
like oh you know maybe I have a 100
different devices uh or rather 100
different instruments in my portfolio
now I need one active websocket or
service and event or something like that
per instrument to get the prices. Uh
maybe that's not so feasible because
it's going to put a lot of load on that
device. We're going to use a lot of
data. We're going to use a lot of
battery and so it really ruin the user
experience. So we want to try and keep
it to a single active connection per
client. And then additionally, uh, if we
do have a client that's connected from
multiple devices, because you can have
multiple phones, you can have a phone
and a laptop, ideally we want those to
be connected to that same server, right?
Because they're going to be requesting
all the same information. There's no
reason that we want to basically be
duplicating all of that work to a couple
of different servers. So ideally what
that means is just that uh you know
we're going to perform some sort of
consistent hashing via load balancer
when we connect via our client device
and then that's going to point us to the
right server that has all the
information that we care about. Okay.
And then finally, so let's imagine that
the client is connecting to some sort of
server to get all this pricing
information. Uh we're going to call
these the user servers, at least that's
what I'm going to dub them for the sake
of this video. We don't want those
listening to the exchange directly
because as I mentioned if you have tons
of user servers because we have tons of
users and each one of those is listening
to an exchange or perhaps even multiple
exchanges uh then it's going to cost us
a lot of money. We have to pay for a
bunch of extra uh subscriptions and that
would be bad. So if we're Robin Hood we
probably don't want to do that. That's
going to be a lot of duplicate work. So
we're going to try and avoid this. So
the first thing that I'm going to start
by talking about is actually placing
orders. Um, so basically the gist of
this is that again Robin Hood is a
brokerage. They're not an exchange.
They're basically forwarding your orders
to the exchange. Now, in reality, they
do something called payment for order
flow, which I don't want to get into too
much, but the gist is that, you know,
Robin Hood will say, "Oo, I want someone
who wants to buy a share of Google
stock. Uh, hey Citadel, can you go
decide which exchange this is going to
for me?" Citadel, you know, pays them a
couple pennies for the right to decide
which exchange it goes to. And then
Citadel, you know, makes a market on
that exchange, hopes to trade against
the customer, and makes a little bit of
money. gist is, you know, topic for
another day. And frankly, it's more of a
a legal regulatory topic than anything.
But, uh, yeah. So, the gist is we're
basically sending our order to some sort
of gateway and then it it gets handled
for us. So, um, let's see. We're going
to basically place an order in our
gateway and then once we place an order,
it actually might take some time for it
to be filled, right? There's no
guarantee that me saying, "Hey, I want
to buy a share of Google," is actually
going to find a counterparty to sell me
a share of Google. It might happen. it
might not. And basically, until I
explicitly get that order filled or I
cancel it, that order can basically sit
on the exchange the entire time doing
absolutely nothing. So, you know, I'm
just going to use the term pending for
that. And then, of course, if you do
have a pending order that has yet to be
filled, you can cancel it. And so, for
cancelling orders, now we have some sort
of race condition, right? At least
internally in Robin Hood, we have a
concept of which uh pending orders a
user has open. But we need to be sure
that when they click the cancel button,
we actually cancel them in the exchange
first before reporting to the user that
their order was canceled. Because if we
don't, what could basically happen is,
you know, we tell them the order was
canceled and then the order could
actually be filled right before we go to
the exchange and cancel it. So it's not
a bad raise condition. The gist is
basically first you want to go to the
exchange, cancel the order, and then
once the exchange says yes, you've
successfully canceled this, then you can
report back to the user that it was
canceled successfully.
Cool. So, let's go go through uh the
order placing diagram. So, I'm just
going to to quickly outline this to make
it clear for everyone. So, imagine we've
got this Robin Hood client over here and
he wants to place an order to buy a
share of a stock. The first thing that
he's going to do is probably, you know,
hit some Robin Hood server and that's
going to put it in some sort of pending
orders table. Right? So, we've got our
orders table over here. I'm using my SQL
because I would prefer to just have a
single leader. Keep everything simple. I
don't really want to deal with any write
conflicts. I don't want to deal with uh
stale reads here. I just want to read
from the leader, write to the leader. Uh
I think we can shard this out amongst
user ids to make sure that uh you know,
we have sufficient right throughput. But
the gist is the orders table is
basically going to contain my user ID,
what stock or option it is that I want
to order, the quantity of it, the
status, which originally would be
something like pending, and then some
sort of order ID itself, which you know
we can autogenerate, doesn't really
matter. The next thing we're going to do
once we have this pending order in the
database is we can go to our order
gateway. This is where we're going to be
doing all that payment for order flow
stuff, which again in of itself is uh
basically a bidding process, but I'm
going to abstract that all away for now.
um just is from here we then go to the
exchange, we place some order, the
exchange is going to probably give us a
separate ID that they made up on their
end, some sort of exchange ID and then
now the problem is you know if that
order were to be filled and you know we
hear from the exchange that the order
was filled, we need to be able to
basically map it back to a Robin Hood
order ID because the exchange order ID
is not going to be the same as the Robin
Hood order ID. So, at this point, once
we get that exchange order ID, we
probably want to go to some other
database table, which I'm going to call
like the order mapping table. Again,
just keep it simple, put it in my SQL.
Uh, we can just shard it on the uh the
hash of the exchange order ID. So, we
can make sure to effectively just
roundroin all of these requests and make
sure load is distributed evenly across
the databases. And what that table is
going to have is basically the exchange
order ID that the exchange just gave us,
the user ID uh so that we can quickly
figure out which uh partition we need to
go to in this orders table, and then the
order ID itself. And so then we also
have a bunch of listeners that are
basically trying to listen from the
exchange, seeing all the trades that
were done. And then if they recognize a
particular exchange ID based on what's
present in this table, they can go ahead
and update this orders table over here
to say that an order was not just
pending but now that it's filled. Okay.
Similarly, we might not fill every
order, right? We may just choose to
cancel some of them before they're
filled. So in this case, what we can do
is like I mentioned, you want to go to
the exchange first, actually cancel the
order and confirm that it's been
cancelled. So step one is that we go
over here. Step two is that we take our
Robin Hood order ID and figure out the
exchange order ID for it by going into
this order mappings table. We then go to
the exchange, cancel it, and then once
we hear about that successfully, we can
go to our order table and uh basically
put in the new status as canceled. So
hopefully that all makes sense for
everyone.
Okay, now we're going to discuss the
actual pricing because this at least in
my opinion is kind of the meat of the
video. I think it's hardest to actually
figure out the stock prices and
distribute them accordingly. So, let's
go ahead and discuss that. So, this is
going to be um you know like a little
bit of finance context that you do need
to solve this problem. Otherwise, I
think it would be a little bit too basic
and not that interesting in the first
place. So, when you have a stock or an
option in real life, there's not really
an inherent price for it, right? There's
just what will uh people are willing to
pay. So, let's imagine we're talking
about one share of GameStop, right?
Let's say I'm willing to pay $3. I'm
willing to buy it for $3 and Techle is
willing to sell it to me for $5. So
basically, I think this thing is worth
less than Techle does. We're not going
to trade with one another because we
can't decide on a price for it. Trades
themselves will actually happen when
basically I'm willing to buy for more
than someone else is willing to sell. So
let's say I actually wanted to buy this
thing for $6, Techle wanted to sell for
$5. We would actually exchange that
share and we would trade at some price.
Now, depending on the exchange, it
depends what uh price we would use. It's
probably going to be between $6 and $5,
but uh you know, hard to say exactly
which one. So, there's going to be some
sort of trade price, right? So, the
question is, you know, how is it that we
actually determine the price of the
asset itself? You know, are we going to
use the trade price? Are we going to use
some combination of the active bids and
the asks where the bids are just how
much people are willing to buy for? The
asks are how much people are willing to
sell for? Well, it kind of depends,
right? I mentioned those over here. We
have the the last trade price. We have
the, you know, the highest buy price and
the lowest sell price. And we can
average those. Um, but this actually
gets a little bit more complex, right?
Because in fact, not only is this stock
offered on just one exchange, it's
actually offered probably on multiple
exchanges, especially if we're talking
about options. So, we can have people
who are willing to buy the option and
willing to sell the option on multiple
different exchanges. They might not even
be able to trade with one another
because they're on different exchanges,
but they may they may still uh find the
stock or the option to be worth some
amount. And as a result of that, uh that
does give us some pricing information
about it. As you can see, I've got a
lovely ambulance in my background, which
is one of the perks of living in New
York City is that you hear this stuff
all the time. Additionally, if we really
wanted to get complicated with it,
instead of uh just doing an average of,
let's say, you know, the best bid across
exchanges and the best offer across
exchanges, I could do something like a
volume weighted average, right? Because
I might be willing to say, uh, buy at $3
for 100 of the share and then someone
else might be willing to sell at $5 for
200 of the share, meaning they want to
sell a quantity of 200. And then you
could use some sort of weighted average
between the two of those to basically,
you know, push it towards the the sell
price because they're willing to to
trade at a higher quantity. So, there
are plenty of different ways to actually
compute the price itself. I think I
probably spent too much time in that uh
original Robin Hood video discussing how
we would actually do those from like a
data structures and algorithms
perspective. And to tell you the truth,
I think that's a good exercise to do on
your own, right? decide on a price that
you want to use, figure out uh you know
what type of data structures you would
actually want to use to get there and do
so efficiently. But right now the main
thing is we have information coming from
many exchanges. We need to aggregate it
in one place, decide on a price.
Cool. So what do we actually have so far
that we have discussed? Well, basically
we've got myself over here. I'm the
client. I'm going to be reading my
positions from some sort of database
table. And as you can see here, I
basically said, okay, well, we have an
orders table. We can create this
positions table using derived data
change data capture have a Kafka
consumer basically update the total
position in the the full positions
table. Easy enough. Uh another thing
after reading our positions is then you
know we've logged on we've read our
positions. Now we want to go to some
sort of load balancer because we want
based on our user ID to connect to one
user server which is going to be
providing us with the prices for all the
things that we care about. This is very
important because as we mentioned we
only want to maintain one active
connection per client device and we can
do so via websocket so that in real time
we can basically update that user server
with which symbols we care about and the
user server can update us uh with the
prices of those symbols. So we do want
birectional communication here. Uh we
don't want to be rescending headers all
the time like via a long pole or an HTTP
request and we do probably want this
stuff in real time. So, it would be
great to be able to use something like a
websocket. So, the gist is like I
mentioned, we would say, okay, I want
I'm interested in the prices for GME.
I'm interested in the prices for
Dogecoin. Let me go ahead and get them.
And then the user server now it says,
okay, well, now I have to fetch the
prices for GME and Dogecoin. We've got
all of the exchanges over here, which
can be sharded in a variety of different
ways because, you know, different
exchanges have different network
topologies themselves.
So, how are we going to go ahead and
basically dissipate the prices from the
exchanges over to our user server? And
that's what we're going to spend the
rest of this video talking about.
So, the first thing that I want to talk
about is the concept of this exchange
layer, right? So, we've got all of these
Exchange servers over here. They
basically publish out data via UDP. And
again, it's expensive to subscribe to
this data. So we want to keep this
exchange layer which is directly
listening to all of the data regarding
the trades that were made on these uh
stocks and options and the actual bids
and asks available for these stocks and
options. And we want to make this layer
as small as possible.
So like I mentioned uh that data gets
published over UDP multiccast again not
too important kind of implementation
specific and uh typically they'll do
some amount of sharding but again
depends on the exchange certain
exchanges have to shard certain others
don't uh and so basically uh again we're
not going to be talking about uh the
architecture of the exchange in this
video but the gist is that uh we want to
keep that layer as small as possible. We
don't want one exchangefacing server per
user, right? If we had one of these user
exer uh one of these user servers for
every single user and they were
listening to basically all the exchange
data to get the prices that would be
very bad because it would be very
expensive. Cool. So again, ideally what
we want is to basically just have you
know for each of these exchange guys
over here we want one server listening
to each shard or perhaps one server
listening to multiple shards. The gist
is we don't want basically 10 servers
listening to the same shard over here
and all getting that data. Now we may
end up having two by virtue of you know
attempting to achieve fall tolerance.
And we can do this uh basically via an
active active or some sort of active
passive configuration. So active active
uh they would basically both be
listening to the exchange and they would
both basically be publishing redundant
information uh to the remainder of our
system. And in an active passive
configuration, they would both be
listening to the exchange, but only one
is actually publishing data. So the
advantage of the active active
configuration would be that uh price
updates would be published twice.
However, there wouldn't be any downtime
if one of them went down, right? Because
the other one would just still be
publishing. Uh that being said, we do
need a little bit of extra logic to
handle the duplicate price updates. Uh
how could we do that? Well, presumably
because all these exchanges are pretty
much ordered within a partition, you
could use the sequence number of every
single trade or something like that uh
to basically ignore updates from the
second device. Or you could just say,
okay, well, I know this incoming uh
price update just came from device
number two. I only care about updates
from device number one, so I'm not going
to listen to this for the moment. Um
active passive, basically, we only
publish one time. However, if uh the
active server goes down, we basically
need Zookeeper to register that. We need
it to update its config. We need
everyone else to understand that. And
Zookeeper by virtue of, you know, being
something that employs distributed
consensus can be a little bit slower
than the typical database. And so maybe
we'll have a slight downtime of like a
little under a second or something if uh
a node fails. When I say a little under
a second, I have no clue. It could be a
few milliseconds. We would have to check
it in practice. But the gist is in
theory at least I would think you would
have a little bit more downtime uh
running an active passive configuration
but the logic would be a little bit
easier to deal with.
Okay, so we have all of these publisher
nodes, right? Listening to the various
shards of the exchange and actually the
multiple exchanges, right? Because at
least in the above video, we've got two
exchanges, right? A and B. And this one
uh A has multiple different shards. And
so we want to ideally keep it to
basically one or two exchange publishing
servers that are listening to each
shard. But from there, oo, great voice
crack there. From there, we basically
want to be able to aggregate prices,
right? because because of the fact that
there are multiple different exchanges
that are publishing prices for a given
asset, right? Let's say we were talking
about a GME option. So, a GameStop
option that can be published on multiple
different exchanges. And as a result of
that, we basically need to take all of
the information from each exchange about
that particular product and aggregate
it. And so, what we can do is use
another server in order to do that. And
that's what I'm going to dub the pricing
layer. So, the pricing layer is going to
do two main things. The first is that
it's going to take in all the
information from the exchange publishing
layer and it's going to aggregate it for
a given ticker. So this could be like a
GameStop option, it could be a Google
stock, anything along those lines. And
number two is that it is going to be
responsible for acting as the middleman
for delivering prices to the user layer.
Now, we're going to talk about how um
you know this server in particular might
have a lot of load on it by virtue of
the design I've chosen here and how to
mitigate that. But for now, let's keep
things simple. So basically imagine we
have this pricing server for GameStop.
GameStop stocks trade on both exchange A
and exchange B. And so what we have, you
know, this this is all not us, right?
This is all just exchange architecture.
Robin Hood starts over here. These are
our listeners. And so this exchange
publishing layer, we're going to have
one node for exchange server A, one node
for exchange server B, and they're
basically both going to be publishing
those trade prices uh over to our
pricing server, which can then aggregate
them and say, "Ooh, you know what? The
new price is actually 1 cent higher than
it was before. Let me go ahead and uh
notify all of our user servers, which
are connected to me via a websocket."
So hopefully that makes sense for now.
And of course, if um you know, we're not
just doing this off of the last trade
price or the last done price as it's
actually called, and we're doing this
off of some sort of stateful
calculation, maybe a moving average,
maybe we're looking at the active bids
and asks, we're going to have to keep
some state in here. And so, you know, in
order to make sure that it's fault
tolerant, perhaps we would also want to
do some amount of like state machine
replication where we have a backup over
here. And all the publishers that are
publishing to this guy also publish to
this guy. And then we've also got
Zookeeper over here to perform failover
in the event that our primary goes down
because every piece of our back end here
we do want to be fault tolerant. And the
way that we tend to do that at least
when all this stuff is being kept in
memory is via state machine replication
with a failover. Cool. So let's go ahead
and shard it on the hash of the tickers.
That is one thing that I didn't mention.
This guy is just going to be responsible
for GameStop. maybe a couple of other
tickers, but uh we do ideally want even
load on all of these pricing servers.
That being said, in the case of some
tickers, generally they're just going to
be too expensive, right? Um if you're
familiar with the American stock system,
uh you know, there are certain things
that just tons of people trade. There's
one thing called the SPY, which is a
very popular index that pretty much
everyone trades. And it would be hard
for me to believe, for example, that for
that ticker in particular, due to the
just sheer amount of volume of bids and
asks and trades on it, that one
particular server, even if it's super
super beefy, could handle it. So, in
this case, we may actually have to do
some extra work. So, we can be
overloaded on the pricing server in two
senses. For starters, this guy over here
can publish too much information to it.
And then secondary, we can have tons of
different user servers that are
interested in getting that information
via websocket on our pricing server. And
as a result, uh, you know, we can have
problematic things going on here where
we basically have to push that data to
too many different places. We have too
many active connections and then we're
in trouble.
So what can we actually do to mitigate
the load? Well, number one, in the case
of the exchange publishers, perhaps what
we could do is actually basically just
throttle how often we publish, right?
So, I mentioned this in particular for
the last trade case because there if
there are tons of trades, uh, you know,
maybe we only publish, uh, one out of
every 10 of them because probably it's
going to be the case that all of those
trades are happening at the same price
and then maybe every 10 or so maybe
we'll see a little bit of fluctuation.
Uh perhaps we could also keep a little
bit of state in those exchange
publishers and publish an average price
over them. Right? So I see the last 10
trade prices. I calculate the average
and I only publish onetenth as many
messages to my pricing server. So that's
an option if you want to be uh you know
pricing all these things off the last
price that they traded at. However,
another option that we have is to again,
like I mentioned, um price them off of
like the open bids and asks in the order
book. Uh where the bids are just how
much everyone is willing to pay and the
asks are how much everyone is willing to
sell for. If we wanted to do that, well,
what we could do is each publisher for a
given exchange could basically, you
know, build up some local state of those
bids and asks, calculate one price every
couple of seconds or not every couple
seconds, but maybe every half second or
something like that, and then publish
that out to uh our pricing layer, and
then the pricing layer would again, you
know, take the average or aggregate them
somehow over all the different
exchanges.
Uh or instead of doing any of that, we
could send a full snapshot of that order
book. Either way, I think this is all
implementation details. As long as you
make note of the fact that there are
many different ways of computing this
pricing with your interviewer and ask
them how they want the pricing computed,
then I think you can go uh a lot deeper
into this. Cool. And then the second
aspect of this is well, if a lot of
users are interested in the prices of
one particular asset and we only have
one pricing server for that asset, how
can we actually disseminate all of these
prices uh for that one asset to all of
our users that care about it? So again
the problem we can run into there is we
have too many active connections and
that would be bad. So at least in this
case what I would recommend doing or I I
guess recommend is a strong word but
what uh what I think about doing is
basically you know resharding right. So
you can basically uh take a bunch of
other servers for that particular super
popular asset uh put them up as
effectively just pseudo pricing servers
and then push all of our pricing
information from our one pricing server
to those pricing servers. And then
ideally we're not pushing it to too many
places and each one of those pricing
servers can handle a bunch of websocket
connections. So what does that look like
in practice? Let's imagine it's 2020.
Everyone cares about GameStop again. So
we've got our GameStop pricing server,
which is super overloaded. What we do
instead is we go ahead and set up all of
these auxiliary pricing caches.
We publish to, let's say, just two of
them for now, but maybe, you know, in
reality we'd want to publish to 10 of
them. And then when a user is interested
in the GameStop price, rather than
connecting over here, you know, we use
some sort of roundroin load balancing to
randomly attach us either to here or to
here. And ideally, all of these caches
should have relatively even load on
them.
Cool. So, let's go ahead and bring
everything together as we have spoken
about it this entire time. So like I
mentioned the first aspect of this whole
thing over here is that a client can of
course place some actual orders and the
way they would do that is by hitting our
order service. The order service needs
to basically have some sort of orders
database so that a client actually knows
you know what pending what filled what
canceled orders they've made in the
past. I think using my SQL here uh is
going to keep it simple. I don't think
the write nor the read throughput on
this table is going to be super high
because I would expect that we're
probably just going to read it once when
we open up the app. And we're probably
just going to write it whenever we place
an order. And it's not like people are
just like spamming orders every two
seconds. People aren't really
algorithmically trading on Robin Hood.
And if they are, they have a problem. Uh
again, we can shard that on user ID. The
reason being that if I'm a user and I
want to read all of my uh orders, it
would be great if they were all on one
single partition and then just index
those on order ID. So, it's easy to find
a particular order ID for a given user.
Next, we also have our order mapping
database. The reason that we need this
is because um when we actually go to the
exchange and place an order, it's going
to give us some ID, but it's probably
not going to be corresponding to the one
that we have in Robin Hood. And so, we
need to uh a way of basically mapping
our exchange ID to uh the order ID in
Robin Hood. And so, the way that we can
easily do that is just by sharding on
the exchange order ID. So, you know, you
go to some load balancer, say, "Hey, I
have this ID right here. what partition
does it live on? Then you go to the
right instance of your order mapping
datab or your order mapping database
partition, fetch your Robin Hood order
ID and handle it accordingly. The last
piece of the puzzle is going to be this
exchange order gateway uh which
basically is just going to act as a
proxy for doing all your payment for
order flow stuff. But the eventual
result of this is that that order is
going to be placed on some exchange. We
don't know which. It doesn't really
matter. It's abstracted away from us.
Not too important. So number two or
piece number two of this puzzle is, you
know, if I'm a client and I have 10
things in my portfolio, I need to
actually be able to see the prices of
those ideally in relatively real time.
It may be the case that, you know, if
Robin Hood decides, hey, people don't
actually need to know uh the price of
all their assets in real time, but maybe
every 1 second we can update them. Maybe
this websocket over here that I'm
connecting to the user server could
become something like a poll or a long
pole or we pull on an interval. But for
now, I'm going to act like uh we do want
these updates in relatively real time.
So, the way that we actually go ahead
and connect to a user server, like I
mentioned, is we want to do it based off
of our user ID. So, if we have multiple
different devices for a given client,
they're all connected to the same guy.
So, the way that we can do that is just
by putting some load balancer in the
middle of things. Uh we hit the load
balancer, it tells us which user server
we should be connecting to, and then we
establish a websocket connection there
to basically enable real-time
birectional communication. Uh everything
is of course going to be listening to
Zookeeper including our load balancer,
including our pricing servers, including
all of our exchange publishers as well
because we need our active passive
configuration for all of these guys. And
so from there, basically our user server
now has to gather all of the pricing
that it needs. So the user server can
say, "Hey, uh for user one or user
Jordan, he's interested in GME and AMC."
And then Zookeeper will say, "Oh, okay.
Well, if you're interested in those
things, you should probably establish a
websocket to this guy over here and this
guy over here. At which point, what's
now going to happen is that uh these
guys are the pricing servers, and they
basically need to aggregate a single
price for all of those tickers. The way
that they do that is by having a bunch
of publishers who listen to exchange
data, like this guy over here, publish
all of the data to them, and then they
can statefully aggregate it in memory
per symbol that they care about. And so
the way that they're going to do that
is, you know, maybe we have a bunch of
different publishers. The publishers
themselves are also listening to
Zookeeper to know where they should be
forwarding all the relevant information
to and then they can forward it to the
proper pricing servers, which again are
sharded on the actual symbol of the
financial asset. So you know, you listen
to Zookeeper Config, it says, "Oh, GME
is up here, AMC is down here." So maybe
this guy, publisher 3, is publishing all
AMC prices and publisher one and two are
responsible for GME prices. Again, like
I mentioned, for particularly busy uh
assets, it's possible that publisher one
and publisher two may have to do some
sort of throttling or extra logic on
their end to actually, you know, come up
with a slightly aggregated price for
that particular exchange or whatever
they're listening to. And then there
would be a little bit more aggregation
on the pricing server itself. Well guys,
hopefully this video made a little bit
of sense. Um hoping you're enjoying it
and uh thanks for all the great feedback
on um all the the Substack notes that I
put up. I'm going to try and uh get all
of the actual systems design problems
notes up within the next couple of days
as well. So uh hopefully those are
useful for everyone. Anyways, enjoy your
week and I will see you in the next